for the 33rd movie in the MCU the
Marvels is a surprisingly light and
wacky Cosmic Adventure will the ending
still has massive ramifications for the
future of Marvel on the big screen at
the start of the Marvels our three leads
are in very different places both
emotionally and physically Kamala is
riding high off of her heroic Ascent at
the end of Ms Marvel drawing fresh fan
arts of herself and Captain Marvel in
her Jersey City bedroom Monica is
investigating a strange energy
phenomenon on aboard the saber space
station orbiting Earth and Carol is as
usual alone riding through the empty
Blackness of the cosmos with no one but
Goose at her side after the cre Warrior
Dar Ben locates a powerful bangle just
like kamala's she begins tearing holes
in SpaceTime to restore the cre home
world of Hower to Glory this causes the
three Heroes abilities to become
entangled meaning that whenever two of
them power up at the same time they swap
places what is happening to me the
ensuing chaos bring Cala face to face
with her Idol and Monica face to face
with the aunt who abandoned her together
they tried to stop Dar Ben from stealing
various planets Resources with mixed
results they do manage to confront some
of their own demons however preparing
them for a showdown with DAR Ben on
Earth as her crowning move she aims to
steal kamala's bangle and use the
Amplified power to take our son but she
has to get through the Marvels first
we're a team no no no no no we're not a
team we're not a team as Dar Ben begins
her attack over Earth the saber station
starts to destabilize but with many core
systems already knocked out there aren't
enough Escape pods to get everyone to
safety thankfully Goose comes in clutch
by birthing a hord of flurin kittens
about the
[Music]
station oh my god when the marbles
arrive they help Nick Fury chase down
all the saber folks so that the flurin
can gobble them up this stalls them in
the kitty void like tummies effectively
shrinking the population of the station
and allowing them to fit inside the cats
in the remaining parts it's a bizarre
and hilarious sequence actually set to
memory from the musical Cats but rest
assured everyone is regurgitated safely
on the ground I can't can you I got it
meanwhile Camala Carol and Monica face
off against darban they defeat her and
Carol agrees to a tentative piece she
promises to use her powers to restore
Hala sun and doing the damage
unintentionally rought by her
destruction the Supreme intelligence in
Captain Marvel of course Darin double
crosses them steals kamala's bangle and
launches herself into the void with both
Quantum bands darbin rips a hold in
SpaceTime clean through to an alternate
reality vaporizing herself in the
process Carol retrieves the bangal gives
them both to Kamala and together they
power up moniker enough that she can fly
to the other side of the hole and close
it tragically though she's trapped there
as Carol can't save her in time with uh
saved darb Ben defeated and Monica lost
in some strange unknown Carol decides to
finally settle her battle with the cre
she returns to Hala where the dying Sun
barely lights the sky anymore then in a
staggering display of her power she
flies straight through the star
energizing its core reactions with her
energy and Reviving it to its bright
glowing Glory the annihilator as the cre
calls her throughout the movie becomes
the savior of the entire race for
Captain Marvel this is a big deal she
reveals throughout the film that a
conflict with the cre still largely
defines her life the violence they
committed against her alienated her from
everyone she once knew as family at the
same time her Vengeance against them
only led to more violence as the entire
world of Hala fell into a quick decline
by repairing Hala son Carol shows that
she can be a force for creation as well
as destruction this closure combined
with her experiences with Kamala and
Monica finally allows her to move on and
return home to Earth this could also
finally Mark the end of the
long-standing crease scroll conflict the
movie suggests that both species are
finally ready to invest in peace and the
healing of Hala might be all the cre
needed to give up on their evil Crusade
at last with a cre chapter finally
closed Carol goes home or rather she
goes to a new home but one that's very
familiar we see the Khan family help her
move into Maria and Monica Rambo's old
house in Louisiana from the first
Captain Marvel movie dressed in regular
Earth attire Carol finally SE is ready
to stop moving around for a little bit
throughout the movie we learn how much
guilt she carries from her time with and
fighting the cre but now that she's made
peace with that part of her past she
decides to stop running of course she
has an ulterior motive in moving into
the old Rambo house as she tells Camala
she's just taking care of it while she
waits for Monica to get back she has no
idea where Monica could be or whether
she'll ever return but that doesn't
dissuade her from staying even with
Monica gone she's not going to abandon
her again in another scene on the saber
station we see that Fury misses her too
the final scene of the Marvels takes
place in New York City but Kamala
confronts none other than Kate Bishop a
Hawkeye sent me here on official
Avengers business I'm his partner best
friend Kate the whole thing plays like a
spoof of the Nick Fury post credit scene
from Iron Man as Kate comes home to find
Kamala sitting in an armchair cloaked in
darkness Camala puts on her best Fury
impression but it quickly gives way to
to her own FASTT talkinging quirky
Persona she tells Kate that she's
putting together a team which at the
moment it's just the two of them
provided Kate accepts she assures her
though that she has feelers out there
mentioning amman's daughter Cassie Lang
specifically despite the somewhat clumsy
proposal Kate Smiles suggesting that
she's down for the team up this seems
like an obvious setup for the of
theorized Young Avengers movie the MCU
was introduced a ton of new heroes in
Phase 4 and Phase 5 any combination of
these characters and others could form a
new superhero team and the ending of the
Marvels seems to set that up perfectly
there's only one credit scene in the
Marvels positioned between the first
round of main credits and the standard
credits that come after in it we see
monik awaken in some kind of medical
facility groggy but alive after her
Cosmic outing she turns and sees none
other than her own mother sitting at her
bedside albe it's a pretty young version
of her when Monica calls Maria mom the
older woman looks her strangely
suggesting that she's never seen Monica
before then everything gets turned on
its head when Kelsey grammas Hank McCoy
AKA Beast walks into frame fully blue
furry and dressed in a lab coat outside
the glass walls of the medical room we
can see the iconic round X doorway from
the X-Men movies this and Grandma's
presence both suggest that we are in
some version of the fox X-Men universe
as grandma played Beast all the way back
in 2006's X-Men the Last Stand Strong
Theory he mentions that Charles will
want an update on their guest and in the
last shot we see Maria's new superhero
costume a red jumpsuit that evokes a
comic book character binary binary has a
strange and Powerful connection to Carol
Danver in the Marvel Comics as they're
one and the same it's complicated it
should be interesting to see how this
new version of the character plays into
the mcu's X-Men
storyline the ending of the Marvels is
more about the action beats and future
setups than it is about larger themes or
ideas but that's not to say that the
film is devoid of meaning quite the
contrary by the ends the biggest
resounding theme as it is in so many
modern blogbusters is the importance of
family be it born or found all three
main characters of arcs relating to
family at the beginning of the movie
Carol has cut herself off from all forms
of family she carries so much shame and
guilt that she believes she deserves to
be lonely and she's scared of getting
close to anyone again because of the
fear that she'll lose them of course in
the end it's her reunion with Monica and
her new relationship with Kamala that
allows her to heal Monica likewise has
built a wall of professionalism around
herself resentful of Carol and scared to
get close to anyone after the death of
her mother in the end she saves the
entire world and possibly the universe
because she trusts the other two marvels
Kamala is the only one of the three who
already has a strong family and we see
just how much that empowers her though
her mother is always scared for her she
ultimately accepts that Kamala is
destined for something greater she
encourages her daughter her to be a hero
but also reminds her that she'll never
let her go the Marvel's isn't really
Captain Marvel 2 but it does give more
closure to Carol's story than it does to
Calas or monikas the latter is now stuck
in a whole new reality and the former is
just beginning what's hopefully a long
and successful superhero career Carol
doesn't retire by any means at the end
of the movie but she does wrap up the
arc that began back in the first Captain
Marvel for decades Carol tried to repair
her memories and reclaim her life but
she did so alone in the cold vacuum of
space it's clear she viewed this as
Penance but she can't heal properly
until she lets people back into her life
at one point Kamala tells Carol that she
made a tough call because that's what
Carol would have done you shouldn't try
to be like me Carol says him response
full of self-loathing maybe it's
reconciling with Monica that gets her
over that hump or it's kamala's
unabashed reverence for her perhaps
there a realization that she can use her
powers to heal really it's a combination
of all those things that allows Carol to
finally forgive
herself as fun as the Marvels is on its
own Merit many fans will likely be even
more excited by the future projects it
may be setting up the biggest of those
is the long awaited MCU version of the
X-Men most likely Marvel Studios will
want to make its own X-Men movies but
the story could also take place at least
in part on Disney plus the slow roll out
of these new X-Men has confused things a
bit as well we got Patrick Stewart
backers Charles Xavier in Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness Kelsey
grammar's Beast appears in the Marvels
and Hugh Jackman is set to return as
Wolverine in Deadpool 3 you have
questions but as long as the Multiverse
era of the MCU continues there's no way
to know how important those actors will
remain Disney would probably want to
fully recast the X-Men for a new
generation for now fans will have to
keep waiting the other big thing set up
in the Marvels is the potential Young
Avengers project or whatever the team
that Kamala Khan and Kate Bishop are
forming will be called in embracing the
franchise's younger Heroes could be a
great way to softly reset the MCU but
that's also a big risk the one thing
that the Marvels doesn't clearly set up
as a Captain Marvel 3 but that doesn't
mean that it won't happen Carol ders is
back on earth now so she could be poured
into any number of upcoming stories her
new Louisiana Home places her in close
proximity to Sam Wilson and his family
who also reside in the state perhaps
we'll get a Captain Marvel cameo in
Captain America Brave New World
[Music]
he